fighting piracy which again is an
organized cyber crime
requires a more holistic approach uh
both on the defense side so you have to
protect your service you have to protect
your content you have to make sure that
the people that are accessing your
service are the ones that are paying but
on the other end fighting uh pirates or
piracy operations the the commercial
operation of it in their own turf
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet yael
finaro evp of security cena media israel
jael is an executive vice president of
cinema security business and the head of
cena media israel cinema is a leading
technology company working with the
world's leading streaming platforms
studios and sports leagues to protect
their content from industrialized piracy
and to provide consumers the best
possible experience for consuming the
video content yale has more than 25
years of experience in the technology
industry in the areas of strategy m a
innovation business development and
post-merger integration prior to joining
cinemadia yale served as vice president
of corporate development of cyberark
software where she was responsible for
leading the company's strategy and for
generating new growth activities through
organic and inorganic initiatives
yeah el finaro welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
how are you
i'm very well thank you thank you for
having me
i'm really excited to talk to you about
your your career you have such an
incredible journey
from from doing the corporate
development investor relations at nds
group pick and then being a director
within cisco and vice president of
strategy and iar at fruit rome and then
vp corporate development in cyborg i
have to understand all these different
positions but but now most recently
executive vice president of security
at cena media and obviously before that
also
senior vice president of corporate
development
now looking at uh you know the
entertainment world and monetization and
video yeah
what's common about everything you've
done here if you had to draw sort of a
line between these different positions
in your career how do you sort of
describe it to yourself
so um i think that
the common thread is really the triangle
of strategy communication
you know financial or or kind of uh
execution and delivery of goals
and throughout my life i've i've dealt
with strategy with kind of setting this
this long-term goal and and devising a
plan of how to get there in uh using uh
multiple uh ways it could be uh mo a lot
of my professional life has been through
m a
and uh so so you know you you're trying
to um to think where you're gonna want
to get to you identify the targets you
you check that it works from many many
perspective and then you execute the
transaction and integrate it into the
company that you're acquiring it for and
you make sure that the goals are are set
um and
but in order to do that you need
a very good financial understanding
because if essentially this is how the
world measures uh company companies and
communication uh
both external to communicate to the
world what you're doing to communicate
the story the vision
uh
and but also most importantly and that's
kind of what i'm
mostly uh dealing in the last uh
probably three years at cnn media is is
is also internally and making sure that
the people that are
uh that are supposed to deliver the
vision and make it happen and make it a
reality they're behind you and they
understand why it's exciting vision they
understand what their role in in in
making that vision a reality is and and
basically just taking you uh taking them
with you on on the journey so it's
really kind of strategy communication uh
financial that is kind of the where i'm
the common thread throughout my uh my
career
and you've obviously spent meaningful
time at at all these different companies
that you've been a part of what what
have been some of the things that
have guided you towards deciding you
know where to spend such a big part of
your career you've seen in some
companies you've spent three four five
years how do you decide which companies
you're about to dedicate yourself
um for for the long run what what are
the factors there
uh actually it's quite simple um it's
it's two very simple factors uh not in
that order uh of of importance one is an
interesting industry that something hap
interesting is happening there so
cyber security you know media and
entertainment uh both
super interesting industries and you
know in the last three years the
combination of so the combination of
cyber security with media and
entertainment industry
and the second one is people
very very very simple uh if you're um
surrounded or working with uh good
smart um people that are you know
visionaries that are our doers uh that
you're basically having fun working with
then you stay this is where you stay
so it's it's it's quite it's quite
simple
i it sounds like it but i think that
this some that within the simplicity
obviously there's different ways to
gauge things whether it's intuitively or
whether it's through some research and
understanding and i'm sure that the
decision-making process
while it may be diluted to two simple
factors there's a lot of intricate
details that go into
from experiences that you've had and
tell me a little bit about cinemadia and
and how entertainment is is reshaping
you know and it's sha and it's reshaping
itself as it evolves
absolutely so um
um the media and entertainment business
has gone through massive
transformation uh in the last probably
six to seven years and accelerated one
over the last um
three years coveted helped massively uh
to accelerate like many other things
that it has done it accelerated the
uh the revolution also in the media
entertainment in in moving it from
um you know broadcast uh cable satellite
mostly uh to streaming uh netflix had a
huge uh impact on on that and uh
and the production of content the amount
of content that is being produced today
um high value content it has probably
more than doubled just in the last year
we're talking about probably more than
200 billion dollar uh that is being
spent
on original content
uh and and and that amazing content
which we all enjoy watching and we all
kind of love and it fills our our time
with uh with fun needs to be monetized
right so how how is it monetized the the
business model in the past was very
simple i produce you know high value
content i license it to
you know a yes or or a sky or or a
comcast or whoever that is in that
particular country they pay me a
carriage fee or something for my channel
or for my content
that model is not available anymore
you know for many reasons one you know
pay tv is just not as popular and b
um the the content owners want the
direct relationship with the uh with the
consumers they want the uh to be to feel
them and to monetize the content
directly so they all most of them go d2c
or direct to consumer and they set up
their own streaming platforms which
of course causes the uh the effect that
you have so many different uh platforms
and if you wanted to watch the content
you watch you need to to have five six
seven different subscriptions
uh all with different passwords or with
different user experiences all uh um so
so you're viewing as a consumer much
better content but your experience has
been impacted significantly
and the uh tell me a little bit more
yell because this is you touched a
fascinating point here for me the
relationship that
that brands want with consumers more of
a d2c approach rather than the ones they
may have had in the 90s or early 2000s
where it was pretty pretty indirect
so
absolutely i mean they all um understand
that the the way uh um the way of the
future is to have uh engagement uh with
uh with the content and in many cases
also with
other things that they have like if you
think you know a disney is a brand hbo
you know warner is a brand they have
parks they have movies they have
seriouses they have merchandise they
have you know many things amazon right i
mean they have the amazon
service the the e-commerce service and
then they have the amazon prime as as
the content apple has
a big ecosystem and content is
is part of that and they um you know and
we see that also with uh you know in
india and in many places uh around aipac
and and in europe
where they all understand that the only
way for for them is to have a direct
connection uh link with the with the end
consumers to understand what they want
and to be able to uh monetize it either
through subscription through advertising
through pay-per-view through merchandise
uh through the whole ecosystem that they
want to build around it of course you
can extrapolate that and think metaverse
and you know where where where it could
go uh gaming uh you know a bigger a
bigger more
um you know more broad relationship that
the brands will have with uh with their
with their end consumers
and that of course is driven by
technology right
100 and i guess this is where cinema
comes in right yes so cinematic comes in
in in in three different places uh in
this in this transformation that the
media industry goes through
one um has to do with the uh
uh the you know distribution of the
content i mean we have you have a lot of
content you want to uh to distribute
that you want the user experience to be
um you know
excellent and when you're watching a
football game or basketball game or
whatever your favorite sport is you want
to watch it near real time and while in
satellite and cable it was fairly easy
to do because the latency was quite um
you know the technology was that just
allowing you to do that in ip
distribution it's harder to do so we we
invest a lot and we have a lot of
technology that deals with the
distribution of the video to end
consumers and the whole user experience
around that so how fast how well can i
find the content you know the uh uh the
whole you know aggregation of it uh from
different platforms so uh again i can i
can find everything in one place i can
access it from one place that's the
whole distribution and kind of user
experience the second big one that has
two legs is monetization right because
uh
if you if you think about the financial
model and there are numbers out there um
if you are uh the the income that um um
a producer of content uh will get from
additional subscription to their own
platform be it you know their own
streaming platform versus what they used
to get from
cinema release and licensing of content
to pay tv
is is is harder to to match i mean they
would get probably less money uh um
direct money related to um uh to the
release of of original content through
their their platform
uh and it's competitive and churn is
quite high because the loyalty i mean
i'll subscribe to the service to watch
this movie but then i'll disconnect
because i don't want anything else
so it's it's the whole monetization that
is is start is is very very challenging
um and that has two aspects from our
perspective one is to find new
monetization ways i advertising that is
more targeted that is more relevant for
um
for consumers that are watching uh
streaming versus pay tv
so it's more targeted ads it's more
content aware um ads and therefore fewer
ads but higher value
the second one which is the one i'm i'm
spending most of my days on is piracy
so piracy is um unlike what we like to
think about you know young people
sitting in the basement and kind of uh
peer-to-peering uh uh content it's it's
not that what we're fighting is
organized crime that is a well-oiled
machine
that is
operating basically streaming platforms
that is selling subscriptions to end
users
and it looks and and smells like a like
a streaming platform with one major
difference that they don't pay for the
content uh as as much of course as
somebody else because they
either steal it or they source it from
somebody else that that steals it right
and they also do the mega aggregation
because they they're not limited by
rights in any way so they can give you
all the sports in the world in in one
place and
fighting piracy which again is an
organized cyber crime
requires a more holistic approach uh
both on the defense side so you have to
protect your service you have to protect
your content you have to make sure that
the people that are accessing your
service are the ones that are paying but
on the other hand fighting
pirates or piracy operations the the
commercial operation of it in their own
turf and this is why
we kind of set up um basically a cyber
team uh that that kind of learns the
pirate
piracy ecosystem as if it was cyber
crime right i mean you know learning
their platforms their their
uh what they're using how they're
operating the commercial relationship
between them and we have a set of
technologies and capabilities that allow
us to to disrupt that
that pirate service
basically killing the motivation of the
pirates to continue operating and making
sure that legit users i mean users like
you and me
would rather pay
uh you know 15 a month to
whoever the legit service is and not
attempt to go to the to the to the
piracy domain because it's associated
with you know crime effectively
so as you're building as as you're
building these products in your and it
sounds like you're also at this
inflection point and deep at the core of
the the shift in consumer behavior and
shift in the way that the media is being
is being consumed by consumers around
the world because you have to have a
true deep understanding and looking into
the future what what factors of consumer
behavior do you need to take into
account today you know in the early 2022
as you're you know an executive within
cinema what what kind of questions do
you need to be asking in order to make
sure that you're continuously on top of
the game besides of course the whole
issue of of the cyber crimes which which
are of course not a new phenomena you
know i remember utorrent
from from years ago i think it's just
accelerated obviously because now the
aggregations are
pretty much more accessible given that
there is much much more content
yeah it's it's it's not not only the
accessibility of it but there's also the
legitimacy of it it's it's almost legit
right to to to do that and that's also a
matter of culturally right in a legal
framework and all of that so yeah i mean
you asked about what and by the way yeah
i'm gonna i'm i'm sorry to bother you
but this is just a fascinating
conversation for me but so it so with
the growing trend of legitimacy what
what are the drawbacks of having these
platforms exist because i think it's an
important understanding to get to the
core of why why is this a problem for
the world to have these illegitimate
aggregators exist
so in very very simple simplistic uh
terms uh if i'm investing uh i don't
know 10 billion dollar in content or
even you know one million dollar to
produce a piece of content and in order
to get the return on it or or to to
justify the investment i need to get i
know 3x 4x
and i can't get it because um other
people are monetizing uh that assets
that i've invested in
then it's just the economics don't work
or for for long for for the long term
now of course we we
have in our mind the um the content
owner like you know the disney or you
know the the the sports i mean we deal a
lot with sports yeah so you know you say
okay so they'll make a bit less money uh
from from from their their rights but
what happened is that there's a whole
ecosystem that is impacted behind that
content in the you know
series and in the movies it's the actors
it's the producers it's the studios and
all of that and in sports it's the the
fees from the licensing of the right the
media rights funds the clubs
and it funds not only the premier league
or the the first league uh clubs but it
finds also the other leagues in in the
country so and and it goes into the
ripple effect is there's
there's a whole ecosystem that that
relies on these uh on these revenues
um uh and therefore it does have an
impact uh on ongoing uh motivation and
ability to continue investing in good to
content and entertainment that we all
enjoy right i mean we all want to enjoy
it
definitely and so now going back to to
the question of consumer of the shift in
consumer behavior yes
so um
we we are a b2b company because we work
with service providers and content
owners and sports leagues uh which of
course makes our job
really fun right i mean the people we
recruit we tell them
oh you're going to watch football you
know most of your working hours which of
course allows us to to attract good
talent but uh
um
but we are b2b but we work with come
with the b with the enterprises that
works mostly with consumers and
therefore in order to develop our
products our services and
and we have to understand user
motivation
uh
so on the um
on the user experience on the
distribution side we need to to
understand and in many cases we would
get this information from our customers
they would tell us what
what's their pain point what are they
not managing to do and and it will be
around user experience it will be around
my my users want to find their content
uh quickly and they want to watch
together they want to be able to watch
together with their friends on um
kind of on social media but but watch
the content throughout the app or
we're doing uh consumer studies on what
drives people to go and watch piracy and
in many cases it will be the uh the
content that they can't find in in their
country that that would be the trigger
this is what they'll they'll they'll
start doing and and then we work with
our customers to say hey
so you need to make sure that this and
this content which we're seeing your
consumers in your country watching make
sure that you have it on your platform
even if it's a pay-per-view but just
have it
so um
so that the
consumers can have that choice so that's
more in the immediate side on the
long-term side of course we're watching
trends like you know the generations
that you know my kids don't watch tv uh
they
they watch youtube they watch tick tock
they watch other things so what would be
the entertainment pattern
of the younger generation uh will they
watch tv or i mean tv has a sense of
video right in the broader sense would
they watch it when they grow up and they
have a family and and or
what are the habits that that will they
will develop and therefore our
technology needs to enable it um
fascinating just fascinating and yeah i
think that i'm leaving here with more
questions than answers which is great
those are the the best episodes that i
have and i and i think that you're
no you're we're we're talking in such a
timely space right i mean if we had this
discussion five years ago obviously the
consumer behavior was different and if
it's ten years ago then definitely an
effort i bet that if we talk about this
episode next year it'll again shift and
i think that it's awesome that you get
to be at the forefront of these changes
both from a a regulatory cyber
perspective thinking through okay what
is the actual snowball effect that is
being created here but also in terms of
in terms of the consumer behavior and
how things are shifting and why cinema
is positioned in a very very interesting
place in the market today and so y'all
thank you very very much for your time
and for your energy i already want to
book you for another episode a year from
now so we can talk about how consumer
behavior has shifted again
but it but it's just awesome and thank
you for uh sharing your intro for
sharing your insights
absolutely it was a pleasure thank you
for for having me
[Music]
you